I've been called a futurist by many
folks out there I'm comfortable with the
label I I think that as an architect and
an urban designer it's our job to be
clairvoyant it's our job to propose
something that doesn't exist it's the
amount of time or the scale of time that
that proposal situates itself in that
maybe makes me a futurists more than
just an architect
is the work we're doing in practical
well I would say no because it's based
on current problems it's based on
real-world everyday issues they're big
issues and I think because they're big
issues there's there's a kind of fear
about making big moves or gestures to to
solve them and so when I hear that our
work is impractical I often para fit
paraphrase john f kennedy and he said if
man created problems man can solve them
so if this problem is really big you
know our energy crisis climate change
etc we are going to need solutions that
match that scale so i don't think that
we're being impractical I just think
we're putting as many ideas out there as
we can and and concepts that are
hopefully grounded in off-the-shelf
technologies or proven thoughts from
some time ago that could a good crew
that make this change happen I mean if I
was to talk about a practical answer to
dealing with our energy crisis in the
United States I would agree with the
Obama administration i would say every
American should just change the light
bulbs and weatherize some buildings if
we started weatherizing buildings for
heating or cooling now very cheap to do
with weather strips etc rubber strips or
you know changing light bulbs to compact
compact fluorescents despite the issues
of mercury which isn't exactly right we
would say forty percent of the energy in
the United States this doesn't take a
rocket scientist to figure out this we
have known for about 30 years give or
take they're the signal of this
intention has been communicated by our
government by our scientists by our
designers by the everyday person we have
long since understood that solving
problems with the way we live today when
it comes to the environment is actually
pretty easy to do so the average
American Homer Simpson hasn't invested
in these compact fluorescent light bulbs
not really interested so far so I think
right now we've got about a five year
limit to get on board with this plan
otherwise you know I
there'll be some penalties I would be so
concerned with the governmental
penalties I would the penalties that the
earth will return to us